and I think God like made Kanye right
and he could have used this stuff for
good or he could have used it for evil
and like for a while he used it for evil
right you're such a
I love that you you know I mean come on
this catchy song but but now you have
the masses you know screaming about a
message that's not good and that's what
Kanye played into but I also think that
the best like Servants of gods were also
villains because some like Redemption is
like inspiring to people and coming back
from like being that like everyone roots
for the underdog and I think sometimes
like God sends people to be the underdog
and overcome it to inspire people